and auto insurance.
Get a quote today.
>> Laura: I'M GOING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW I CAN BE AWAY THIS
WEEKEND BECAUSE A HALF-MILLION
PROTESTERS ARE EXPECTED TO
DESCEND ON WASHINGTON TO PUSH
FOR MORE GUN CONTROL AND SCHOOL
SAFETY.
HUNDREDS OF OTHER PROTESTS ARE
PLANNED AROUND THE WORLD ON THE
SAME DAY AND WE ARE TOLD THAT
EACH MARCH IS BASICALLY
STUDENT-LET, BUT DID STUDENTS
REALLY ORGANIZE ALL OF THIS IN
THE FIVE WEEKS AS THE FLORIDA
SHOOTING?
LET'S LOOK INTO WHO WAS REALLY
BEHIND THIS WITH WASHINGTON FREE
BEACON REPORTER STEPHEN.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THIS IS JUST A BUNCH OF KIDS
HAVING FUN AND DOING WHAT'S
RIGHT IN A TIME WHEN WE NEED TO
SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> CERTAINLY THAT'S THE MEDIA
NARRATIVE ON THIS PROTEST.
IT'S JUST THE KIDS SORT OF PUT
THIS ON THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE JUST VERY TALENTED
KIDS.
>> Laura: ARTICULATE, ON TV,
60 MINUTES.
>> THE REALITY IS THAT THAT'S
NOT TRUE.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF GROUPS THAT
ARE HELPING ORGANIZE THIS EVENT,
EVERY TOWN FOR GUN SAFETY,
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG'S.
>> Laura: HE'S PERSONALLY WHAT
AND HOW MUCH MONEY INTO THAT
GROUP?
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS.
THAT'S HIS BIG ISSUE, GUN
CONTROL.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY EVEN CREATED A NEW GROUP
CALLED STUDENTS DEMANDS CHANGE.
>> Laura: BECAUSE IT'S A 501
C4 IS ERODING YOUR PIECE, IT'S
LIMITED ON WHAT INFORMATION WE
CAN GET, BUT WE CAN BET, AND
THIS HAS COME OUT THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE A MASSIVE PUSH FOR
VOTER REGISTRATION AND EACH OF
THESE SITES THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE A CANVAS WITH VOTER
REGISTRATION STATIONS.
SO THE GOAL HERE IS?
>> IT'S TO CHANGE POLICY, CHANGE
THE LAW.
>> Laura: THE GOAL IS TO TAKE
BACK POWER.
THE MIDTERMS, DRIED THE ELECTION
NARRATIVE INTO 2020 AND IT'S THE
SAME KIND OF FOLKS THAT WERE
BEHIND THE WOMEN'S MARCH,
CORRECT?
>> YES, SOME OF THEM ARE
ABSOLUTELY INVOLVED IN
ORGANIZING THIS.
IN THE GROUP ITSELF, THAT GROUP
IS NOT JUST SPENDING THE MONEY
THEY WERE RAISED ON THIS
PARTICULAR MARCH.
THEY'VE ALSO SAID THEY'RE GOING
TO SPEND A GOING FORWARD ON
OTHER LOBBYING.
>> Laura: VERY INTERESTING.
WE SHOULD BE ALL EXCITED BECAUSE
GEORGE CLOONEY AND HIS WIFE AND
HIS TWO CHILDREN ARE COMING
BECAUSE HE WROTE A CHECK THERE
IF THEY JUST SOLD COMPANY -- I
THINK HE MAY PERSONALLY 500 KNOW
ENOUGH OF THAT, NOT A BAD PAYDAY
SO HE WROTE A $500,000 CHECK,
CHUMP CHANGE, FOR THIS GROUP.
HE'S GOING TO BE THERE, SO THEY
WILL HAVE A CELEBRITY PUSH MUCH
LIKE THE WOMEN'S MARCH.
THIS IS ALL PART OF AN
ORGANIZATIONAL EFFORT TO DRIVE
THE POLITICAL NARRATIVE,
CORRECT?
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IT'S NOT JUST GEORGE CLOONEY
EITHER.
IT'S ALSO OPRAH WINFREY DONATING
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS, THERE
CERTAINLY A LOT OF --
>> Laura: THE OLD -- THEY ARE
ALL BACK!
THE STUDENTS ONE ON
"60 MINUTES."
THEY ARE GETTING THE FULL MEDIA
PUSH AND IT IS GOING TO BE
BLANKETING THE COUNTRY.
WE SEE IN THE GRAPHIC.
DO WE HAVE THE GRAPHIC WE CAN
PUT UP FROM THE MARCH?
YOU CAN EVEN PUT THE RED FLAG.
YOU'VE GOT TO HANDED TO THEM.
THAT GOT THE MONEY BEHIND THEM
AND THEY GOT THE ORGANIZATION.
WILL THIS HAVE BIG IMPACT, DO
YOU THINK, IN NOVEMBER?
IS THIS A BIG ISSUE THAT DRIVE
THE ELECTRIC?
>> IT HASN'T BEEN IN THE PAST.
PROBABLY THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION
OF WHAT THE ORGANIZERS -- IN THE
PAST GUNS HAVE BEEN AN ISSUE
THAT REPUBLICANS -- VOTERS HAVE
GONE TO A REPUBLICANS FOR
POLICIES.
>> Laura: THE SECOND AMENDMENT
TYPES ARE SAYING THIS IS UNFAIR,
THEY'RE COMING AFTER OUR GUNS,
LAW-ABIDING PEOPLE'S GUN, WE GOT